il ya bientôt deux mois nous sortions de
huit semaines de confinement imposées
par la crise sanitaire une période
difficile pour beaucoup une source aussi
d'inspiration pour d'autres les
yvelinois de jolis prod en ont profité
pour réaliser un court métrage ça
s'appelle confinement intime c'est
disponible sur youtube le film
questionne notamment un sur les la
liberté les notions de liberté et de vie
privée pour en parler julien denervaud
et frédéric landat bonsoir bon ça on ça
alors julien denervaud à jolie prof vous
êtes vice président à la direction
artistique et sur ce court métrage vous
occuper la fonction de coréalisateur et
coscénariste est aussi acteur et on vous
voit dans ce court métrage et frédéric
landat vous êtes trésorier de jolis prod
et acteur dans confinement intime une
précision cela a été tourné entièrement
à distance comme notre interview
ce soir dans le journal je vous propose
qu'on regarde tout de suite un extrait
mettez ou la tat quart de notre chambre
sort de la catherine papa sinon ils vont
pas me trouver sur de la bordaises jeu
thales
though i à bonjour papa tient au bignon
à clermont ferrand
ta drôle que tu sois quand celle là bas
pendant le confinement tu joues ta mère
je ne sais pas c'est vrai que je n'ai
pas entendu des films mon corps déchirés
dans le placard de notre chambre va la
chercher s'il te plait je vais la
chercher
ap un extrait de confinement intime un
court métrage tourné je le disais
entièrement à distance déjà une première
question comment vous est venue l'idée
pendant le confinement de réaliser ce
qu'on métrage
bon alors c'est très simple en fait
pendant le confinement
il ya un moment donné ça nous a manqué
de pas nous voir d'habitude on se voit
régulièrement fait plein de projets
artistiques autour du cinéma du théâtre
de la musique bref énormément de choses
et là on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
on a une envie commune de créer et on a
des choses à dire par rapport à la
liberté la vie privée l'intimité des
gens avec toute cette place de la
technologie aujourd'hui enfin la place
qu'elle prend dans notre société et qui
s'est encore plus accentuée avec ce
confinement et les visioconférences
on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
on a eu plein d'idées avec tous les
jolis producteurs et tous les jolis
productrice on a mis toutes ses idées
ensemble et ensuite on s'est lancé dans
l'écriture d'un scénario avec olivier
salazar qui a fait un premier jet et
ensuite qui a été et bien amélioré et
continuer avec salomé carsen claire
soudier et moi-même et de là on s'est
dit bon bah maintenant on part là dessus
et on va se faire un film pendant le
confinement et qu'on sortira à la fin du
confinement et ce travail à distance
frédérick ça n'a pas été trop difficile
de pouvoir tous vos coordonnées pour
pour ce ce court métrage bat déjà on
peut dire que c'est déjà une performance
artistique que durant ce tournage en
fait on a été on a dû gérer en fait le
côté atiné le côté et le côté technique
on était un peu livré tout seul en
autonomie donc moi c'était vrai après on
a vraiment s'inquiéter
qui était vraiment une performance sans
fin et crème confirmez vous avez dû vous
même vous cadrez faire le preneur de
sons en fait gérés tout l'aspect
technique depuis chez vous directement
c'est ça on a géré la lumière on a géré
le plan en ingérer le son si on puisse
après à côté on avait notre notre texte
aussi à à bien s'en rend bien à bien
récitée pour pour les séquences et puis
après je peux aussi rajouter que on a
tourné en plan séquence
donc en fait c'est le plan séquence en
fait comme dans le cinéma c'est c'est
une scène où on coupe à la caméra
pendant tout le long et il faut savoir
que si jamais le on a une moindre petite
erreur ou un objet de recommencer la
séquence juste depuis le début c'est
quelque chose quand même de deux bras de
confier mon a reçu très bien de halleux
à le faire à distance julien avec les
moyens du bord c'est étaient tournées
ont rejoint sur sur des images à la
webcam téléphones tablettes
on le disait des acteurs aussi multi
casquettes c'est toute une réflexion
qu'il a fallu avoir en tant que co
réalisateur une ré nouvelle réflexion
sur la manière de faire ce court métrage
c'est ça il ya vraiment là par rapport à
la coordination à cette réflexion la
réflexion à la fois sur le fond du film
quel message on va faire passer et sur
tout l'aspect technique comme le
souligne fred à l'instant ben voilà
c'est que la visioconférence tout le
monde imagine la visioconférence qui l'a
fait pendant le confinement avec sa
famille ou avec son travail en
télétravail etc
c'est des choses qui prennent un peu la
tête des fois au bout d'une heure de
réunion en conférence est pas la même
chose qu'en physique est là il faut
imaginer que c'est des réunions pendant
deux puissants mars avec un tournage
début mai donc que des réunions en
visioconférence et un tournage 24 afin
de 8h à 22h le soir en visioconférence
donc pour diriger les acteurs c'est
compliqué ou dans l'énergie pour la
faire passer ces shows en termes
d'actifs
puisque les acteurs ne se voit pas ne
peuvent pas se renvoyer de l'énergie
physiquement ils font juste s'entendre
par des oreillettes
voilà donc il ya toute une logistique
qui est mise en place derrière c'est
pour ça qu'on parle de performances
artistiques aujourd'hui sur terme de la
création puisque devient un délai très
court
il ya des moyens
très réduit ça nous a coûté 0 euros un
parent électricité de chez nous et notre
internet et de quoi est il question
alors on l'a compris ça parle du
confinement bien sur ce court métrage
mais quel est le le synopsis alors c'est
très drôle le synopsis on peut pas
vraiment dire je pense qu'ils ont
regardé le film pour pour savoir de quoi
ça parle
en revanche il faut bien avoir en tête
que l'histoire est un prétexte au film
vous avez le concept du film avec la
volonté les messages qu'il ya derrière
et cette histoire en gros le
téléspectateur va être embarqué dans une
histoire et la fin sera interprété par
chacun et chacun on va être libre
d'interpréter de la manière qu'ils le
souhaitent ce film est de comprendre les
choses qu'il veut en comprendre mais il
ya énormément de sous texte autour de la
vie privée et de l'intimité de la
liberté la place de la technologie
aujourd'hui du confinement on a aussi
devant une télé réalité qui a été faite
par alexandre pidoux et florine célestin
qui étaient confinés ensemble c'est un
couple et on a joué sur ce parallèle
avec la télé réalité où les gens vont
s'enfermer volontairement voilà il se
confine volontairement dans un endroit à
la recherche de la notoriété
aujourd'hui nous on s'est tous retrouvés
confiné involontairement pour se
protéger donc du coup il ya ce parallèle
la et et tous et double personnalité
avec des gens dans les réseaux sociaux
etc
voilà je vous laisse voir le film parce
que c'est à vous de vous faire votre
propre interprétation et tous les codes
notamment de la télé réalité on les voit
notamment s'engueuler mais oui c'est
vrai il faut il faut regarder ce court
métrage le tout d'ailleurs avec le
prisme de la webcam on peut le dire ça a
été un petit peu notre meilleur ami
pendant le confinement c'était notre
lien avec la famille les proches
oui totalement c'était c'était c'était
un lien avec tout le monde et là ça a
été en plus nous notre lien social parce
que c'est entre nous côtoient
régulièrement un très souvent et donc là
bas la première idée qui nous est venue
sebha ok on en visio même nom créé
quelque chose et donc on va créer
quelque chose autour de la
visioconférence toujours dans l'esprit
jolie prod donc un joli film avec un
joli scénario est bas dans une jolie
ambiance
voilà donc malgré les difficultés
techniques qu'on a pu rencontrer avec
coupure d'internet orages qui
ils empêchent la connexion etc on est
resté dans une jolie ambiance pendant
tout le tournage et une bienveillance et
d'ailleurs je remercie au passage toute
l'équipe d'avoir tenu parce que c'était
pas facile et on a réussi quoi faire
cette performance je vois qu'ils
essaient frédéric oui là c'était une
bonne c'était de la bonne ambiance sur
sur ce projet abbas était une voix s'est
tue c'est une bonne ambiance et puis une
façon de faire un court métrage match
est différent par rapport au précédent
qu'on a pu réaliser auparavant donc une
bonne ambiance et une bonne expérience
avec très rapidement julien une
dimension yvelinoise la musique est
proposé par un groupe de rambouillet oui
c'est sa part le groupe glisse river
donc c'est un duo de musiciens
compositeurs
il compose notamment de la musique un
peu pour le cinéma et autres ils sont en
préparation de leur album avec et jolie
preuve ce sont des jolies producteur
celui des augustes river on a pu le
retrouver sur notre jolie soirée concert
à l'année dernière à m as à voisins le
bretonneux
donc il ya toute cette dimension est ce
ce maillage tout ce réseau constitue
concret avec jolie prod et que l'on
cherche à développer pour développer les
talents locaux
on ne retrouve aussi à travers ce court
métrage et et puis bah oui cette musique
là c'est un extrait que c'est de leur
musique human on a été choisi un extrait
de la musique et ça colle parfaitement
avec le film donc merci encore à ce duo
de musiciens reggae skriver allez le
voir ce court métrage ça tel confinement
intime c'est disponible sur youtube et
aussi pour retrouver toute l'actualité
de jolis prod vous invite à vous rendre
sur le site internet le lien également
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci à vous
deux julien et frédéric d'avoir été avec
nous merci pour moi c'est un plaisir
pour ce court métrage confinement intime
de jolis prod